Lula optó por desplazarse hasta el hasta
el edificio legislativo en el
tradicional rolls-royce descapotable
antes estaba especulando sobre la
posibilidad de que Lula optara por un
carro blindado hay un mensaje de calma
por parte del mandatario entrante con
esta elección teniendo en cuenta Pues
todos los problemas de seguridad que ha
habido en los días previos a la a la
posesión
un saludo a todos a todo el equipo
famoso y a toda la audiencia si esto es
esto es típico del propio del propio
Lula tenemos un presidente de verdad con
el mismo carácter con la misma fuerza de
opinión que el anterior pero por lo
menos una fuerza de opinión guiada a una
dirección democrática la dirección más
ética Luna tiene una cuestión con el
mismo que es si yo como presidente no
puedo y declaró frases muy parecida si
yo como presidente no puedo caminar
entre la gente que me eligió
En qué país estamos porque voy a ser
presidente Entonces él tiene eso esto
muy claro en relación a su seguridad y
ya miramos Esto justamente esos dos
momentos de votación en la primera
vuelta en la segunda vuelta
sí sin embargo pues la policía arrestó
hoy a un hombre con un cuchillo y con
dispositivos explosivos tratando de
ingresar a la Explanada de los
ministerios estamos ante un riesgo real
de violencia eventualmente
sí estamos en riesgo real de violencia
de un magnicidio
claramente hay hay estos cuatro años
de fuerza de fuerza del odio de una
conclusión de un discurso de de odio y
de fanatismo creó obviamente eh
potenciales actos aislados son de
violencia y que ya se sucedieron en un
montón de momentos y que claro podría
venir después venir a sucederse con el
presidente de la república
Lula tiene seguridad justamente para eso
para evitar que esto pase pero al mismo
tiempo para que él también pueda
ejercer su mandato como él quiere Así
que estamos en una paradoja Claro que él
tiene preocupación con lo que sea la
seguridad pero igual
lo que es necesario es que se mantenga
la seguridad para para un presidente
tanto cuanto para cualquier ciudadano en
Brasil
caigo Ahora sí Entonces quiero que
analicemos el discurso Cuál de todos
estos puntos que él ha tocado cree usted
que va a ser el más difícil para para él
para ejecutar ya como presidente de la
república
mira
Luna tiene
la experiencia de ocho años entonces
cualquiera de los temas que sea
administrativo
tiene su perspectiva de solución
la principal cuestión para este gobierno
Lula está en el mismo problema que tuvo
a 20 años atrás
quiere decir
todo gobierno de Brasil es de coalición
principalmente cuando llega un líder que
tiene una tendencia al progresismo y no
voy a decir solo izquierdo de leche pero
escritorio Vargas tuvo el mismo problema
en su dictadura en 1930
el tubo de codunar El pudo de crear una
coalición
con los descontentos de Sao Paulo
lo mismo Lula hizo en su primer gobierno
en su segundo gobierno en el gobierno de
Dilma y ahora
Entonces
es una situación complicada la cuestión
de la articulación política por tener de
lidiar con agendas muy distintas
pero
Este es el presidente que tiene más
capacidad de lidiar con estas agendas
políticas tan distintas de un país
continental y ya se ha aprobado
competente suficiente para hacerlo
quizás el tema de largo negocio sea lo
de los principales temas pero igual
Lula logró dar la vuelta en eso en su
momento anteriormente Y cuál es el gran
argumento
para vender a grandes compradores es
necesario cumplir con ciertas
reglamentaciones con ciertas actitudes
de preservación
para lograr seguir vendiendo hacia
afuera
Solo falta un presidente
enseñe eso a la clase dominante
agroexportadora y volvemos a tener buena
protección en amazonia volvemos a tener
una buena exportación
volvemos a tener un pecado organizado y
al mismo tiempo mercado que preserve la